j'ouvre le second débat de ce sens
public consacré à l'influence politique
et à l'avenir judiciaire de Nicolas
Sarkozi l'ex-président fait l'objet d'un
livre enquête intitulé Le Parrain qui
révèle notamment le rôle du businessman
conseiller joué par l'ancien chef d'État
auprès de grandes entreprises avant d'en
découvrir les détails famicaer nous
dresse le portrait de celui qui murmure
toujours à l'oreille de la
droite depuis la rentrée il a enchaîné
les séances de dédicaces au contact de
ses fans Nicolas Sarkozi d'oublier son
agenda judiciaire et veut jouer la
modestie je suis un Français qui habite
en France qui écrit des livres
officiellement en retrait de la vie
politique l'ancien président entretient
pourtant une relation privilégiée avec
Emmanuel Macron qui l'a rencontré
régulièrement depuis l'arrivée de ce
dernier à l'Élysée moment clé du
rapprochement entre les deux hommes
pendant la campagne de 2022 Nicolas
Sarkozy déclare son soutien au candidat
Macron après n'avoir pas soutenu
publiquement Valérie pécr à l'aube du N
ena Nicolas Sarkozi rêve d'une alliance
de gouvernement entre les macronistes et
les LR c'est très clair il s'agissait de
d'amener un responsable des républicains
peut-être un ericti ou un autre à la
tête du gouvernement lorsqu'il a été
question éventuellement de se séparer de
d'Élisabeth borne et même avant
d'ailleurs cette cette manœuvre ou ce
projet a échoué et de ce fait les
relations évidemment sont se sont
distendus de la lune de miel à la guerre
froide Nicolas Sarkozi lâche alors
quelques pics contre son successeur
critiquant par exemple la politique de
la France en Ukraine des propos salués à
Moscou qui ont agacé l'Élysée malgré ses
dissonances Nicolas Sarkozi plaiderait
toujours pour une alliance entre Hir et
macroniste aux européennes reste la
question de son influence réelle sur sa
famille politique Sarkozi à droite c'est
le dernier grognard de la droite qui a
encore une influence sur les gens qui a
encore une forme de vraie grande
popularité et qui n'est pas intégré
complètement à l'appareil de renaissance
c'est pas Gérald d'Anin donc il est
capable lui peut-être d'être un
négociateur efficace pour recomposer une
forme de droite une recomposition la
seule manière d'éviter une nouvelle
déroute électorale à droite selon
Nicolas Sarkozi qui se verrait bien
jouer une dernière fois le rôle du
Sauveur de sa famille politique
l'influence politique de Nicolas Sarkozi
son business de conseiller son avenir
judiciaire on en débat avec Étienne
Girard bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
rédacteur en chef du service société à
L'Express co-auteur de ce livre Le
Parrain Sarco après Sarco l'enquête vous
l'avez écrit avec Laurent valdiguier
c'est publié aux éditions du Seuil
Franck Louvrier bonsoir bienvenue maire
LR de Labau vice-président de la Région
des Pays de la Loire et vous étiez
évidemment le conseiller communication
de Nicolas Sarkozi au ministère de
l'Intérieur P pendant sa campagne
présidentielle puis à l'Élysée Sophie
coagard bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue
journaliste éditorialiste politique au
point et Tam tranu évidemment est rester
à mes côté aliste politique on commence
par l'influence il y a vraiment trois
chapitres dans dans dans ce débat on
commence par l'influence politique
comment vous la définissiez vous
définiriez pour parler français
aujourd'hui ti Girard énorme elle est
encore énorme pour vous absolument pour
nous Nicolas Sarkozy hormis Emmanuel
Macron et sans doute Alexis coler le
secrétaire général de l'Élysée c'est
encore l'homme le plus puissant de
France le troisè homme le plus puissant
de France parce qu'il a des réseaux qui
lui per permett de parler d'égal à égal
à Macron même avec un petit ascendant au
ministre de l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin
et puis il fait le GO betweenen
l'intermédiaire avec un certain nombre
de dignitaires étrangers et même avec
des grands patrons en France donc
Nicolas Sarkozi même s'il est retraité
depuis 7 ans maintenant puisque ça sa
retraite c'est c'est les primaire de la
droite lorsqu'il lorsqu'il perd presque
presque jour pour jour il reste dans la
vie politique aussi parce qu'il a choisi
c'est lui qui choisit de rester présent
comme ça dans l'ombre de recevoir des
gens dans ses bureaux de miroménil il
refuse très peu de rendez-vous et il
donneent toujours des conseils assez
pertinents semble-t-il et ceux qui
refuseent de le voir ils se font taper
dessus il y a des offes dans la presse
qui
sortent il y a des conseils de non non
tu devrais pas le nommer ici là VO il
sait faire ouis Sophie car est-ce que
vous pensez à l'inverse qu'on surestime
le l'influence politique de Nicolas
Sarko bah moi je pense qu' il se
démonétise quand même petit à petit
alors il a de beau restein mais
néanmoins enfin qu'est-ce qui se passe
en effet comme le disait Étienne Girard
enfin il se prend quand même deux vestes
électorales de suite euh il est un vrai
faux retraité de la politique ça je suis
entièrement
d'accord il est un écrivain et comme
écrivain on peut pas dire que il soit
sur la pente du succès pourquoi le le
nouveau dernier tome du livre S moins
bien que les précédents c'est ça
beaucoup moins bien beaucoup moins bien
alors on voit bien que il RAM beaucoup
si vous regardez Twitter enfin pardon X
vous voyez que à la moins s'il y a trois
personnes enfin j'exagère un peu il y a
encore il a encore un fan club
mais pour moi il n'est plus la rockstar
de la droite et donc sur Twitter
effectivement dès qu'il y a une file
d'attente devant une librairie où il
fait une dédicace il y a le petit poste
de Nicolas Sarkozy qui qui laisse penser
que une foule
entière absolument énorme vous entend
bien il alimente
lui-même l'histoire de son influence
enfin le c'est absolument indispensable
l'influence elle repose sur la croyance
dans le fait que vous êtes influent vous
êtes influent parce qu'on croit que vous
êtes influent donc si on commence à
moins croire que vous êtes influent bah
vous êtes moins influent pour faire un
peu simple ouais franc Louvrier pourquoi
il y a autant de personnalités encore
aujourd'hui qui défilent parce que ça
c'est une réalité dans le bureau de
Nicolas Sarkozy R deomen de Paris pour
une simple assez bonne raison c'est que
c'est le dernier qui a fait gagner sa
famille politique de la droite du centre
h donc à un moment donné c'est toujours
intéressant quand même de discuter avec
quelqu'un qui a eu les recettes du
succès même si euh pouveit considérer
que tout n'a pas été succès c'est normal
quand on fait de la politique d'bord on
gagne pas tout le temps mais au-delà de
ça je pense que c'est ça qui est
intéressant et c'est vrai que lui il a
la politique dans le sang et on lui
enlèvera pas son sang c'est-à-dire que
c'est pas pour ça qu'il va faire de la
politique active et qui va aller
s'engager qui va aller battre les
estrades et cetera c'est pas du tout le
l'objectif et et non ça pas sa volonté
non plus mais c'est l'idée aussi toute
sa vie quand on le connaît bien il a
essayé de pousser des gens à réussir à
faire de la politique il y a plein de de
gens aujourd'hui qui sont même candidats
à l'élection présidentielle ou ou
peut-être qu'andidat à l'élection
présidentielle qui qui ont été poussé
par lui d'une façon ou d'une autre en
tant que ministre comme dans des
responsabilités X ou Y et donc voilà
donc c'est ça ça l'intéresse aussi de de
Prom mais est-ce qu'il a encore ce
pouvoir aujourd'hui parce que vous vous
dites c'est le trè trè personnel le plus
puissant de France émission aujourd'hui
sur lui si c'était pas intéressant on la
ferait pas j'imagine que vous dcideriez
de parler d'autres personnes donc ça
vous ça veut bien dire qu'à un moment
donné depuis le temps qui fait
l'actualité qui soit aux responsabilités
ou pas c'est qu' l'intéresse et ça c'est
sans doute aussi une autre facette du
personnage c'est que je pense que cette
relation qu'il a particulière avec les
Français pas éventuellement avec ses
fans avec les Français moi j'été très
étonné euh il en a fait beaucoup de
dédicac dans ma ville à La Baule et et
il a fait la première dédicace de son
dernier livre et honnêtement je savait
pas comment ça allait se passer on le
sait pas au départ et il y avait plus de
monde que d'habitude et surtout il y
avait toute une génération de jeunes qui
n'avaient même pas voté pour lui quand
il était président de la République
c'estàd des jeunes ils étaient pas en
âge de le faire VO voilà exactement et
et qui venait là et c'était pas
population qu'on avait l'habitude de
voir dans dans des dédicaces précédentes
parce que je pense qu'aussi il fait
partie un moment donné de d'une histoire
politique et les gens veulent avoir
cette rencontre avec ces histoires
politiques alors quand vous éêteslu
c'est intéressant d'être sur uneénule et
et quand vous êtes pas élu mais que vous
voulez le rencontrer c'est intéressant
d'aller au dédicace donc tout ça c'est
un un mélange imp passionnant et et qui
fait que c'est vrai que c'est le seul
aujourd'hui même si c'est peut-être pas
les ventes des précédents livres
honnêtement il y a beaucoup d'écrivins
qui aimerit avoir ce résultat là en ce
moment ah bien sûr enfin en terme en
terme relatif en terme en terme de
tendance mais vous savez c'est comme les
audiences on fait pas la même audience à
TF1 il y a 10 ans qu'on l' fait
aujourd'hui parce qu'il y a faalisation
des audiences c'est un peu pareil pour
pour le livre enfin ce qui ce qui
m'intrigue je je comprends tout à fait
ce que vous dites et c'est intéressant
de voir effectivement cette nouvelle
génération qui arrive mais j'ai envie de
dire les jeunes aiment aussi les
dinosaures enfin on sait bien que dans
les magasins ça se vend bien est-ce que
Nicolas Sarkozi aujourd'hui est vu comme
un comme un acteur
influent de la politique et comment
dirais-je comme un comme un homme
d'avenir ce qui est pas complètement
enfin je veux dire c'est pas
complètement insensé puisque je me
disais tout à l'heure en préparant cette
émission que en 2027 si je me suis pas
trompée dans mes calculs Nicolas Sarkozi
aura exactement l'âge qu'avait Jacques
Chirac quand il a été élu pour la
première fois président de la République
donc rien ne lui est interdit on peut
pas dire que c'est un dinosaure en terme
d'âge il me semble juste que
euh les jeunes éventuellement sont très
intéressés par cet animal politique qui
est Nicolas Sarkozi par le le
l'extraordinaire parcours de Nicolas
Sarkozi est-ce que ça veut dire euh
qu'il considère que Nicolas sarzi jouera
un rôle de premier plan dans les années
à venir alors je n'en sais rien j' d
cherche alors effectivement tiens on va
l'écouter puisque régulièrement dans
chaque interview il dit qu'il a renoncé
à une ambition politique comme vous
dites il va il va pas battre les tréau
ou se présenter à une à une élection
voilà ce qu'il nous dit je suis très
inquiète ce qui se passe avec
la la
politique moi je ne fais plus de
politique
on a tous
constaté je ne fais plus de politique en
ce sens que je n'ai plus d'ambition
élective électorale mais je suis ancien
chef de l'État c'est normal que je vous
m'inviter gentiment je viens ça
m'intéresse et je vois pas pourquoi je
devrais aller uniquement avec les gens a
qui son des
accords mais c'est une chose de
participer à un débat çaen est une autre
d'avoir une volonté politique je pas
volonté politique je nen ferai plus et
pour moi c'est un
passé que j'ai beaucoup aimé mais c'est
un passé al on est en 2019 et c'est
l'université d'été du du mdeef Franck
Louvrier j'ai quand même du mal à croire
que l'animal politique et Nicolas
Sarkozi ne se disent pas régulièrement
et c'est ce qu'il dit je suis très
inquiet ce qui se passe avec la
politique en voyant les autres faire je
ferai mieux qu'eux jelonge il dit pas ça
et je dis pas qu'il dit ça j'imagine
qu'il le dit non mais trompez-vous c'est
encore plus intéressant peut-être dans
dans la situation qu'il est aujourd'hui
que celle dans laquelle il était
auparavant parce que au moins il a le
confort de pouvoir parler à des gens
sans avoir la lourde responsabilité de
prendre la décision donc je pense que
c'est c'est d'autant plus agréable
surtout quand on a eu la vie politique
qu'il a eu mais dites-vous bien que
c'est sûr qu'il quittera pas le monde
politique ça l'intéresse et ça
l'intéresse depuis le plus jeune âge et
et jusqu'à jusqu'à la fin de sa vie je
pense qu'il sera passionné par ça
maintenant voilà il a il a aussi intérêt
de transmettre et ça c'est important je
veux dire c'est rare aussi parce que
dans notre société mais s'il y a une
petite fenêtre d'opportunité pour 207 il
va la saisirz dans notre société
politique souvent quand on quittait la
vie politique notamment avec des
responsabilités au plus haut niveau
c'était terminé on fermait la porte
parce que d'abord on y lisait souvent
des personnes âgées et donc de ce fait
là la porte se fermait plus vite bon
aujourd'hui c'est plus le cas on a on
s'est rapproché un peu des démocraties
anglo-saxon ou même parfois l'ancien
président parle au nouveau Président ce
qui est pour moi assez rassurant dans
une démocratie apaisée ou même s'il est
pas de la même couleur politique que les
anciens présidents parlent au président
du moment comme il y en a pas beaucoup
qu' on fait le job c'est toujours
intéressant d'avoir des échanges
d'expérienceces donc voilà donc c'est
c'est plutôt sain je trouve ce ce climat
ettienne Girard le fait de garder une
influence politique c'est important pour
Nicolas Sarkozi également pour d'autres
casquettes pourquoi expliquez-nous ça
Nicolas Sarkozi c'est devenu un homme
multicasquette effectivement il a cette
influence politique ça c'est presque son
hobby c'est quelque chose qu' apprprécie
il a effectivement sans doute quelque
part dans la tête un regret une
ambiguité personnelle et d'ailleurs on
lui a demandé je lui ai demandé parce
qu'il a participé il a accepté que il
nous a rencontré deux fois et je lui ai
demandé assez directement s'il pouvait
nous dire qu'il ne reviendrait
absolument jamais en politique et il
nous a dit dans l'océan d'incertitude
qui est notre monde il serait grottesque
de prendre un engage eng agement
définitif et voilà ce qui veut ce qui
veut dire je pense que il ne c'est pas
qu'il ne veut se représenté il l' déjà
essayé ce type de retour mais c'est
c'est Rachid hadti d'ailleurs qui nous
dit ça c'est que même à 120 ans s'il
voit qu'il y a un trou de souris quelque
part alors il le saisira voilà ça reste
en lui et ça restera toujours en lui
maintenant la politique c'est vrai que
ça c'est important pour lui dans sa vie
aussi parce que ça fait fructifier
son business c'est-à-dire que le le
business de Sarkozy est utile pour les
hommes politiques parce que Emmanuel
Macron peut faire passer des messages à
des entrepreneurs à des chefs d'État
étranger via Nicolas Sarkozi et à
l'inverse l'accès à Emmanuel Macron lui
permet de rester toujours
bankableable dans le milieu des affaires
aujourd'hui c'est un Buman c'est un
conseiller auprès de grand chef
d'entreprise ou chef d'État étranger
c'est ça il a ce mot pour décrire ça il
dit je suis un
Advisor Advisor dans le monde des
affaires c'est c'est un un méga
consultant c'est un consultant de de de
grande expérience Advisor après 50 ans
voilà c'est un très très Senior Advisor
auprès de chefs d'entreprise qui ont
besoin pour des raisons X Y d'avoir
accès au président de la Côte d'Ivoire
au dirigeants du
qatarident du Rwanda il fait l'interface
il fait pas que des chefs d'État c'est
aussi comprendre les clés de
l'organisation de notre pays parce qu'il
y a des chefs d'entreprise à juste titre
qu'on pas eu l'expérience politique il y
en a beaucoup et et donc de ce fait là
comprendre comment ça fonctionne comment
comment est-ce qu'on peut défendre une
idée une
position aussi à l'international mais
aussi au niveau national donc c'est
c'est à la fois son expérience qui est
intéressante et et son influence bien
sûr parce que c'est c'est tout toujours
intéressant d'avoir quelqu'un qui a les
contacts pour voir mais dans toutes les
entreprises vous avez ça et donc on en
revient au début il faut que l'influence
soit toujours perçue comme importante
pour que vous la République pendant 5
ans honnêtement il vous reste encore de
be rest pour
paroute quand même des contacts surt le
même réseau que Nicolas sarzi que vous
dites quand on a été président de la
République pendant 5 ans je ne sais pas
ce qu'a fait François Hollande je sais
ce qu'il a fait de son mandat j'en suis
assez déçu et ce qu'il a fait après de
ses connaissan c'est pas la même chose
vous voyez mais chacun sa vie Françis
est haut fonctionnaire à l'origine
Nicolas Sarkozy est un avocat c'est pas
votre avis là-dessus la façon dont
l'ancien président Hollande utilise son
influence effec non il y a pas photo on
est tous d'accord je pense qu'on est
forcément tous d'accord là-dessus mais
ce qui m'avait amusé c'est il y a
quelques années j'ai fait un livre sur
les conseils d'administration les gros
conseils d'administration donc
évidemment je suis tombée sur Nicolas
Sarkozy administrateur du groupe accord
pour ne pas le le citer et c'était à
assez intéressant de enfin moi ça m'a
beaucoup intrigué de demander aux autres
administrateurs comment se comportait
sarcozi dans ce dans ce rôle qui était
extraordinairement différent de de celui
qu'il était habitué à tenir et c'était
très amusant parce qu'effectivement on
comprenait pourquoi à la fois il était
incroyablement utile et pas seul pour
son carnat d'adresse on me l'a confirmé
mais pas que je suis d'accord avec vous
Franck l'ouvrier mais aussi pour une
espèce de vision pour une forme de
comportement c'est-à-dire que dans cet
univers incroyablement policé où tout le
monde s'exprime avec des termes vous
savez technique techno et cetera Sarkozy
parlait avec un mélange de franchise et
de brutalité il faut bien le dire qui
qui réveillait qui faisait un peu de
vous voyez ce que je veux dire qui se un
peu le CER ça peut faire du bien dans un
conseil d'administration est-ce qu'il a
appris aussi le langage de de de de ces
conseils d'administration parce que ça
c'est il a il y a des termes anglais
partout tout enfin c'est parfois
caricatural hein mais d'ailleurs il
maintenant il il parsème ces ces
conversations de mots anglais je suis
pas sûr qu'il s'en rend compte mais ce
qui est sûr c'est que tous les hommes
d'affaires qu'on a rencontré on a
rencontré big on a rencontré la gardèire
on en a rencontré d'autres les moins
connu mais tout aussi important ils
disent tous que Nicolas Sarkozi est
absolument excellent et qu'il est devenu
une pièce maintenant centrale dans leur
business alors il y a le côté carnet
d'adresse mais ce qui soulligne tous
c'est la capacité de travail
extraordinaire de Nicolas Sarkozy c'est
il faut lui reconnaître ça c'est-à-dire
qu'il a eu l'humilité lui ancien
président de se replongé dans les
dossiers de chaque entreprise il connaît
tout sur le bout des doigts même mieux
que certains administrateurs sensé être
des experts de leur domaine si vous
voulez c'est c'est intéressant parce
qu'on découvre cette facette là de
Nicolas sarcoli aujourd'hui mais en fin
de compte c'est une facette qui existait
déjà quand il arrivait pour gérer la
succession d'Alstom il était face au
président d'Alstom et il savait
exactement combien il avait de personnes
dans son entreprise quels étaient les
enjeux et cetera c'est c'est quelqu'un
qui aime rentrer dans les dossiers à
fond et les maîtriser donc c'est pas
nouveau et et de ce fait là c'est vrai
que dans le privé on n pas toujours
l'habitude de voir ça moi j'ai eu la
chance d'avoir les deux expériences dans
le privé dans le public et et c'est vrai
qu'on a pas toujours et c'est pour ça
que c'est un apport d'avoir un ancien
chef de l'État c'est un gros luxe mais
même quelqu'un qui a été dans le monde
de la politique parce que justement ça
ouvre des portes qui sont parfois pas
ouvertes par le monde de l'entreprise
puisquon est dans dans le chapitre de
l'influence politique et de la façon
dont il l'utilise il y a peut-être
quelque chose qui freine son influence
politique aujourd'hui c'est l'amertume
d'une partie de son camp beaucoup de de
LR qui ne digèrre pas on va dire
l'absence de soutien officiel à Valérie
pcres écoutons Bruno retaillon on est le
6 juin 2022 dans la matinale de Public
Sénat c'est terrible mais mais son
attitude a beaucoup déçu au au moment de
la présidentielle parce que on attendait
de quelqu'un qui effectivement est une
forme de de figure tutellaire de notre
famille politique qui qui s'engage et et
beaucoup y ont vu une sorte de soutien
plus ou moins implicite même peut-être
presque explicite à la reconduction
d'émanel Macron qui est un mauvais
président de la République et qui n'est
pas du tout dans notre famille politique
ça n'est pas président de droite manuel
Macron Sophie car il y a un ressentiment
des des électeurs de de droite de la
droite LR envers Nicolas Sarkozi encore
je pense que il y a que le ressentiment
est plus fort chez les gens comme Bruno
retaillot et les gens qui appartiennent
à l'appareil politique du parti des
républicains où là évidemment le
ressentiment est énorme sur les
électeurs c'est plus moi je pense que
c'est beaucoup plus diffus pour une
raison simple c'est que les électeur le
peuple de droite si on ose dire il a
sûrement été déçu par la trahison de
Nicolas Sarkozi mais il a été avant tout
déçu par la prestation de Valérie pcrè
donc
l'électeur j'allais dire lambda ça veut
pas dire grand-chose mais l'électeur de
droite et cetera effectivement est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui il est choqué par le fait
que Sarkozi est plutôt choisi Macron que
pcrè sincèrement j'en doute h on va
justement parler de de du lien entre
Nicolas Sarkozi et Emmanuel Macron
Nicolas Sarkozi on va on a recherché la
la date d'un soutien officiel à l'actuel
président de la République c'est
évidemment entre les deux tours on est
le 12 avril 2022 et là on a choisi un
extrait de d'une intervention de
d'Emmanuel Macron il est à mulouse en
déplacement en campagne électorale il se
dit honoré par le soutien de Nicolas
Sarkozy je le remercie de sa confiance
et de son soutien je pense que c'est
très important et que ça la m'honore et
ça m'oblige et donc je pense qu'il faut
rassembler très largement et j'ai
entendu que sur les sujets de travail de
sur les sujets de travail sur les sujets
d'Europe il son retrouver Tam on vous a
donné un thème ce matin Macron est-il
l'héritier du sarkozisme voilà à ce
sujet de disserte on a envie de répondre
bien sûr en trois parties on a été bien
fort en Momas d'abord la thèse il y a du
Sarco dans Macron du faet à la retonde
l'hyper présidence sarkoziste à la
présidence jupiterienne on a retrouvé
deux présidents qui veulent être partout
et tout décidés ils ont aussi en commun
leur style et leur
provocation un
sad
imbécile choisissez j' avais mis dans le
programme
d'interroger
les concurrents sur la princesse de
CL
plus
contocation moins assumé elles sont par
vois quasi scénarisé et ont chez l'un et
chez l'autre le même objectif trouver un
parler vrai qui risonne avec les
conviction de certains Français mais qui
souvent agressent aussi les autres alors
on a aussi ces points communs le le le
leur goût de casser les codes voilà la
disruption c'est comme ça qu'on appelle
ça rompre avec les codes convenus de
l'exercice politique Nicolas Sarkozi a
inauguré cette pratique et Emmanuel
Macron l'a théorisé cela s'est notamment
manifesté chez eux par le brouillage des
frontières la fameuse ouverture
Sarkoziste qui a vu des personnalités de
gauche comme Bernard couchner Éric
Besson Jean-Pierre jouillet rejoindre
son gouvernement qui a peut-être
préfiguré le en même temps macronien le
ni de droite ni de gauche et de droite
et de gauche l'ADN initiale dansen
marche mais bon les ressemblances
s'arrêtent là ah oui deuxième partie
Thomas antithèse qui se ressemble ne
s'assemble pas toujours c'est pas parce
qu'il y a du SARC dans Macron que tous
les sarkozistes vont s'y retrouver en
macronie en ne soutenant pas la
candidate de la droite Valérie pecrè
lors de la dernière présidentielle on
l'a vu en plaidant pour une alliance
entre Macron et LR l'ancien président de
la République a suscité pas mal
d'oppositions chez les actuels LR conf
faire Bruno rotaillon mais aussi chez
les macronistes et pour l'instant son
projet est resté donc à l'état de projet
il n'y a pas de filiation directe entre
les deux courants politiques l'un établi
sur l'Union de la Droite l'autre qui
s'est construit sans parti préalable
entre celui qui voyait dans les
magistrats un monde de petit poids sans
saveur qui se ressemble tous et celui
qui ne jure que par la technostructure
il y a quand même des personnalités qui
sont passées de col Sarkozi à Emmanuel
Macron voilà trème partie synthèse et
dépassement Thomas c'est le bon principe
et qui fait la synthèse aujourd'hui
entre la Sarkozi et la macronie celui
qui a été le coordinateur de campagne en
2016 de Nicolas Sarkozi pour cette
funeste primaire à droite celui qui
futtigait alors le bobo populisme de
Monsieur Macron avant de devenir son
ministère des comptes publiques et son
ministère de l'Intérieur tiens tiens
tiens les mêmes poste d'ailleurs que
Nicolas Sarkozi j'ai nommé Gérald
Darmanin et parfois on sent que l'un
s'inspire de l'autre regarde regardez je
suis très fier de l'assimilation
française mon premier prénom est Gérald
mon deuxième prénom est Moussa et grâce
au président de la République et grâce à
ceux qui m'ont accompagné je suis très
fier d'être ministre de la République
alors je vais vous dire une
chose tous ces hommes m'ont enseigné à
moi petit français au sans mêlé l'amour
de la France et la fierté d'être
Français d'ailleurs l'actuel locataire
de la place beauovvois a été adoubé par
l'ancien président de la République dans
son dernier livre où il écrit saura-t-il
franchir une autre étape voir l'étape
ultime celle qui mène à la présidence de
la République je le lui souhaite comme
quoi si on n'est pas sûr d'avoir
identifié l'héritier de Sarkozi ça ne
l'empêche pas Nicolas Sarkozi de vouloir
se mêler lui des problèmes de succession
merci beaucoup Tam on reviendra sur
l'affiliation d'armanin peut-être
concernant Emmanuel Macron et tien
Girard est-ce qu'il cherche souvent les
conseils de Nicolas Sarkozi et puis la
question subsidiaire c'est est-ce qu'il
les écoute oui vous avez raison de poser
cette deuxième question il fait mine
très souvent d'écouter les conseils
ou il pour D avec lespous mais c'est pas
tout régulèrement Emmanuel Macron
appelle Nicolas Sarkozi souvent
lorsqu'il a des nominations des
décisions de personnes à prendre il veut
écouter Nicolas Sarkozi qui a toujours
des idées il a toujours des noms dans sa
besace il a toujours un coup d'avance
mais c'est vrai que ce qui agace
beaucoup Nicolas Sarkozi c'est
qu'Emmanuel Macron ne l'écoute pas
toujours mais surtout il joue pas
toujours extrêmement Fran jeux sur ce
qu'il va faire c'est qu'il peut lui
laisser l'impression qu'il va suivre ses
conseils jusqu'à la dernière
seconde Nicolas Sarkozi lui avait
proposé de nommeré Christine Lagarde
Premier ministre pour son deuxème
quinquena Emmanuel Macron n'avait avait
répondu ni oui ni non il a pu avoir
alors finalement il a fait mine de
choisir Catherine Vautrin une ancienne
porte parole de Nicolas Sarkozi et puis
comme ça sans une explication il change
d'avis et il nomme Elisabeth borne que
Nicolas Sarkozi n'apprécie pas du tout
en partie parce qu'elle est une ancienne
conseillère socialiste mais il lui ça
c'est vraiment macronien il lui dit mais
appelle quand même Christine Lagarde
pour lui demander d'aller au kedoret
donc il n'écoute pas les il il écoute
parfois à moitié les conseils de Nicolas
Sarkozi évidemment Christine laarde
refusera de quitter son son poste à la
Banque centrale européenne pour pour
aller au kedoret et ce côté à la fois
mystérieux et parfois dit dit Sarkozi en
privé procrastinateur il met du temps à
prendre ses décisions bah ça énerve
Nicolas Sarkozi qui lui au contraire est
quelqu'un de très fonceur même parfois
impétueux c'est ça a été le nom d'un
livre de Catherine Ney titre d'un livre
Franck Louvrier est-ce que effectivement
il il sort souvent frustré de de ces
rendez-vous
avec pr mais j'ai le sentiment qu'ils
ont plaisir à se rencontrer parce que
d'abord c'est assez gagnant gagnante il
y en a un qui a l'avantage d'avoir
quelqu'un qui a eu l'expérience du
mandat et c'est toujours agrave de
parler un président de la République en
exercice donc je pense que les de oui et
puis s'est gagnant aussi pour
l'influence de Nicolas Sarkozy auprès
des autres c c'est ce don on par tout
qu' autant de rcontre avec François
Hollande qui est quand même son
prédécesseur donc voilà non mais au-delà
de ça je moi je je pense que c'estes
deux hommes de chefs d'État du 21e
siècle c'est pour ça que ça va plus vite
c'est pour ça aussi
que ils sont ils sont très énergisant en
fin de compte tous les deux c'est-à-dire
qu'on le voit bien il y a beaucoup de de
de de pression sur ce qu'ils ont à faire
et ils en mettent beaucoup on n pas du
tout le le le le je dirais le le paysage
qu'on a pu connaître avec jaces Chirac
ou avec François Man ou même avec
François Hollande et et là on a passé un
cap et puis c'est aussi des gens qui qui
à mon à mon avis se regarde comme aussi
des des bêtes politiques c'est-à-dire
que il s'écoute mais il se regarde et on
le voit bien je pense qu'il y a une
forme d'admiration respective entre les
deux après bien sûr que c'est pas les
mêmes bien sûr ils ont pas le même
parcours et puis il y en a au-delà
de de l'expérience de Nicolas Sarkozi et
et d'Emmanuel Macron il y en a qui a
aussi la connaissance du monde politique
ce que n'avait pas Emmanuel Macron quand
il est arrivé Nicolas Sarkozy il connaît
toutes les villes de Fr France ou
quasiment il connait une bonne partie
des élus français donc ça ça aide aussi
dans la conversation on peut tester on
peut faire du N broping comme on dit
aujourd'hui allez autre chapitre
important dans dans ce débat les les
affaires judiciaires déjà pendant la
campagne présidentielle de Valérie pcrè
on va voir un extrait de d'un meeting
les militants qui regrettaient et je
reprends leur terme les casseroles de
Nicolas Sarkozi on est le 4 avril 2022
ce jour-là le nom de l'ancien président
avait été hué écoutant ce
militant pour lequel j'avais beaucoup
d'estime et bien il m'a
extraordinairement déçu pourquoi
pourquoi de pas savoir sur quel P danser
et puis et puis il va picorer dans les
mains
de de Macron nous a foutu dans la merde
avec toutes ces casseroles et puis et
puis la Libye c'est
épouvantable mathiasz est de retour sur
ce plateau bonsoir Mathias pour faire un
point sur ces affaires judiciaires
commence par les affaires en cours alors
le 8 novembre prochain Nicolas Sarkozi a
de nouveaux rendez-vous avec la justice
pour l'affaire big Malion condamné en
première instance à 1 an de prison ferme
l'ancien président a fait appel dans
cette affaire de fausse facture entre
l'UMP et l'agence de communication big
Malion pour passer sous silence un
dépassement conséquent des frais de
campagne lors de la présidentielle de
2012 en 2021 les 14 accusés dont Nicolas
Sarkozi sont reconnus coupables de
complicité de finance ement illégal de
campagne électorale ça c'est la première
il y a ensuite les soupçons de
financement libien pour la campagne de
2007 Nicolas Sarkozi sera jugé début
2025 pour recelle de détournement de
fonds publics corruption passive
financement illégal de campagne
électorale et association de malfaiteurs
en vue de commettre une infraction punie
de 10 ans d'emprisonnement enfin et
c'est lié à cette affaire au début du
mois l'ancien chef de l'État a été mise
en examen dans l'affaire de la
rétractation de Ziad takedin principal
témoin mettant en cause Nicolas Sarkozi
dans les financements libiens les chefs
d'inculpation sont ici recel de
subornation de témoins et participation
à une association de malfaiteurs en vue
de commettre l'infraction d'escroquerie
au jugement en bande organisée et puis
il y a aussi l'affaire pour laquelle il
a été condamné cette fois-ci une seule
pour le moment l'affaire des écoutes
aussi connu sous le nom de l'affaire
Bismut il est ici reproché au 6e
président de la République d'avoir tenté
d'obtenir vir d'un magistrat des
informations sur une autre affaire le
concernant rattrapé par des écoutes
téléphoniques enregistré par son avocat
Nicolas Sarkozi est condamné en première
instance à 3 ans de prison dont un ferme
pour corruption et trafic d'influence
une peine confirmé en appel cette année
en 2023 et à laquelle il faut ajouter 3
ans d'inéligibilité l'ancien président s
pourvu en cassation et puis pour être
complet il y a aussi les affaires dans
lesquelles il a été mis hors de cause
alors on peut citer par exemple
l'affaire B en cours du nom de
l'héritière de l'empire L'Oréal pour
laquelle Nicolas Sarkozi a été mis en
examen pour abus de faiblesse trafic
d'influence et recell mais en 2013 faute
de preuve suffisantees il bénéficie d'un
non lieu autre affaire dans laquelle
l'ancien président de la République a
été mise hors de cause celle pour des
pénalités de compte de campagne en 2012
à l'époque Nicolas Sarkozi doit
rembourser des dépassements de frais qui
sont finalement réglés par l'UMP malgré
une enquête ouverte un non lieu est
prononcé Thomas merci beaucoup coup
mathas je vais reprendre le le titre de
votre livre Le Parrain de Sarco à Sarco
l'enquête Etienne Girard pourquoi ce
titre pourquoi le Parin le mot est quand
même assez connoté et violent bien sûr
le mot a été utilisé par Carla Bruni
alors c'est c'est tout le côté piquant
de cette affaire c'était plutôt sur
l'influence politique sûr qu'elle
mettait le même sens que tous les les
lecteurs qui vont Acher livre mais ce
qui est intéressant dans dans
l'expression est qu' il peut avoir
plusieurs sens a un vrai côté mentor un
côté patriarche chez Nicolas Sarkozi
mais c'est vrai que la justice l'a
condamné aujourd'hui deire en appel dans
une affaire en première instance dans
une autre affaire des affaires
politico-fancières et qui laisse penser
que la justice considère qu'il y a un
autre Sarkozi un Sarkozi occulte un
Sarkozi bah qui qui joue avec la ligne
jaune de ce qui est possible le de faire
vis-à-vis du vis-à-vis du droit Sophie
Coignard cette expression le parrain
elle vous semble justifié
caricaturale comment vous la recevez non
elle me enfin j'aime beaucoup les
précautions que que prend Étienne Girard
mais quand je regarde la couverture de
son livre je pense plus à la deuxième
explication qu'il donne qu'à la première
c'est-à-dire ça me fait penser
pardonnez-moi mais à l'affiche du ce
vieux film qui s'appelait le
parrain avec mar brandoau on est plus
dans ce clair obscur et cetera on est
assez peu dans le gentil grand-père
patriarche
ou alors il y a une petite il y a une
petite erreur de communication en terme
d'image c'est tout l'intérêt de vitoc
cor leéon vit cor Leon n y
voilà est un grand-père est et un père
très sympathique et c'est aussi un chef
de bande Moon en l'occurrence un chef de
bande criminel ce que n'est
pas jusce il a été condamné si on veut
disserter sur le titre du livre euh moi
je suis maire et je fais des baptêmes
républicains avec des parins et des
marenes et Parin c'est le protecteur
ouais donc ça peut être vu aussi comme
ça c'est peut-être une vision qui est
biaisée mais en tout cas c'est une
vision c'est aussi le protecteur mais
c'est un peu ça aussi dans son dans son
état d'esprit c'est que il aime suivre
les gens il aime les les accompagner et
voilà donc c'est peut-être la raison
aussi de nombreux rendez-vous dans son
bureau quand vous voyez autant
d'affaires judiciaires
euh comment vous réagissez vous dites
c'est quand même voilà une triste image
de notre démocratie vous dites quoi
c'est un acharnement des juges comment
vous j'ai pris l'habitude depuis des
années de pas de faire aucun commentaire
et laisser la justice faire son travail
et je pense que c'est la meilleure chose
qu'on pe faire aujourd'hui il y a pas de
condamnation
définitive laissons faire les choses
laissons la justice faire son travail et
puis on verra bien ce qu'il en est c'est
jamais agréable pour l'homme et et et
pour lui et moi je suis son ami donc
j'aime pas ça je trouve ça très
désagréable mais voilà malheureusement
c'est la vie aujourd'hui d'autant plus
des hommes politiques ont eu beaucoup de
responsabilité ou de femmes politiques
on le voit bien on est sous pression en
permanence ettienne Girard sa
stratégie judiciaire à Nicolas Sarko et
à ses ses avocats c'est de jouer la
montre depuis des années
parti il y a ce procédé quelque peu
dilatoire effectivement de faire durer
les procédures il fait tous les appels
il fait tous les pourvoir il dit j'irai
même jusqu'à la CEDH donc il ira
jusqu'au bout la cour européne des
droits euré des droits de l'homme voilà
donc dans 10 ans on y sera encore il y a
cet aspect là et puis il y a l'aspect
médiatique il est un peu à l'instar de
maître vergess rappelez-vous il est dans
une défense de rupture c'est-à-dire
qu'il conteste la légitimité de ses
juges il est persuadé d'être victime
d'un complot des magistrats que c'est de
la politique judiciaire c'est comme ça
qu'il explique ça et donc il est
persuadé qu'au bout du compte il les
fera anné pour défaut d'impartialité il
met en avant cette juge qui avait
contesté une dans l'affaire Bismut qui
avait contesté une de ses réformes
finalement avorté du juge d'instruction
bref il conteste tout en bloc et en
détail il ne et il faut aussi dire que
dans de premierers procès dans de
premières affaires l'affaire B encour
vous l'avez cité ça lui à souri cette
défense coûte que coûte crâne dans
l'affaire Bismut et dans l'affaire
bigmion ça lui a pas du tout souri parce
que ce que penseent certains de ses amis
c'est que s'il avait une autre posture
une posture plus humble de moins de
remise en cause des magistrats il aurait
pu écoper de peines plus légères l'un
des sujets que ça pose c'est ce qu'on a
vu avec le monsieur qui qui intervenait
tout à l'heure c'est que ça donne une
certaine image quand même de Nicolas
Sarkozi même auprès de l'électorat de
droite de quelle façon et ben ça
discrédite aussi et bien Nicolas Sarkozi
un peu plus largement la classe
politique ce type d'affaire sopieard oui
pendant il me semble quand même que
pendant longtemps
sur l'électorat de droite son son
système de communication je sais pas ce
qu'on pense francouvrier mais assez bien
fonctionné c'est-à-dire que la manière
dont il s'est victimisé marchait assez
bien à droite auprès de l'électorat qui
disait vraiment queil y avait enfin pour
faire cours de l'acharnement de la part
d'un certain nombre de juges et comme le
disait Étienne gerérard le fait que pour
la première affaire l'affire en cours il
il il est bénéficié d'un nonlieu a
évidemment renforcé l'idée que c'était
de l'acharnement et puis faut
reconnaître que il y avait dans cette
affaire un juge d'instruction qui ne
semblait pas spécialement impartial donc
effectivement ça a bien fonctionné puis
il y a je dirais qu'aujourd'hui on est
dans dans la phase 2 dans la saison 2 où
ça patine ça patine pourquoi parce qu'il
y a un effet d'accumulation comme vous
le disiez fort bien et parce que il y a
un effet de lassitude sur toujours les
mêmes phrases toujours la même rangain
c'est c'est-à-dire la première fois que
Nicolas Sarkozi dit je ne suis pas
au-dessus des lois mais je ne suis pas
non plus en
dessous enfin la plupart des
sympathisants de droite disent bah c'est
bien vrai ça enfin ça paraît être le bon
sens près de chez vous bon la 15e fois
franchement ça fatigue tout le monde oui
je vrais on en est au moins à la 15e
fois oui oui il y a une phrase qui dit
sur les sur les affaires qui résument
tout il estime que c'est les affaires
qui lui ont fait perdre la la primaire
de 2016 il dit en 2016 les électeurs
voulaient Sarco sans les affaires et ils
ont eu les affaires sans Sarco rapport à
l'affaire Fillon voilà donc il estime
que c'est ça lui a coûté quand même sa
vie politique Fran louvri est-ce que ces
relations avec les juges explique pas
aussi une partie de la situation vous
disiez tout à l'heure qu'il les avait il
les avait traité c'était 2017 petit poid
201 j'espère pas j'espère qu'un homme
politique ou une femme politique peut
dire ce qu'ils veulent de des
institution qui fonctionn autour d'eux
ce serait ce serait dramatique de penser
ça donc j'è j'espère pas ça mais en tout
cas c'est vrai que aujourd'hui il se
défendra cûte que cûte mais comme il
s'est toujours défendu depuis toute sa
vie c'est-à-dire que c'est quelqu'un qui
est un combattant et il ira jusqu'au
bout ça c'est sûr et il utilisera toutes
les voix les procédures que lui donne le
droit pour aller jusqu'au bout et pour
défendre sa cause mais c'est normal le
meilleur avocat de soi-même c'est
soi-même la base alors il y a les
affaires judiciaires et puis y a les
affaires tout cours on a déjà parlé un
peu de du business de Nicolas Sarkozi
tout à l'heure mais je vous propose de
de relire de revoir cette phrase qui
lance en petit comité à l'Élysée on est
début 2008 il y a plusieurs journalistes
donc forcément la phrase elle fuite il
dit pour l'instant je fais président
mais un jour j'iraai faire du fric il
tient la promesse c'est ça Ettien Girard
ah il tient très bien la promesse
d'ailleurs il avait dit à un autre
journaliste je ferai du gros argent et
fait effectivement du gros argent
puisqu'il gagne 230000 € par mois en
moyenne qu'il facture non non non ah non
c'est pas ce qui facture c'est ce qui
c'est ce qui est versé sur son compte en
banque même chose voilà donc c'est du
net c'est du net avant impôt pour être
précis et ça on le sait parce que les
enquêteurs de l'affaire libyenne ont
voulu retracer tous ces comptes pour
voir s'il avait s'il y avait eu des
versements occultes en l'occurrence il
en n'y en a pas eu en tout cas lié à la
qui sont qui sont retenus dans l'affaire
libyenne mais on connaît ces revenus qui
sont pour une part ce dont on a parl
tout à l'heure les des des opérations
d'Advisor et pour une autre part quelque
chose de finalement beaucoup plus simple
c'est sont ce sont des
conférences pendant une heure des
businessmen souvent des banquiers
d'ailleurs se payent un discours de
Sarkozi alors parfois il ouais un
discours de Sarkozi il raconte les
souvenirs de son mandat ses rapports
avec Obama ses rapport avec Merkel ses
rapports avec Poutine il donne sa vision
de la démographie mondiale les gens sont
para est-il très content ça se finit
régulièrement en standing ovation et ça
peut être facturé 100000 € de l' combien
vous dites 100000 € de l'heure voilà
j'allais dire est-ce qu'il y a une côte
des anciens présidents est-ce que le
François
Hollande il y a des imprésarios mondiaux
qui vendent les les anciens les
anciens grand les anciennes grandes
figures et notamment les anciens
présidents et il est il est parmi les
les mux il y a une une entreprise qui
s'appelle Washington speakers C ex qui
c'est fa parti hein je crois maintenant
mais vous pouvez avoir Bill Clinton vous
pouvez
avoirand quand vous regardez les tarifs
il est très bien placé vos cololloges
vos événements et il est mieux placé que
François Hollande je repose la
questionors a une question très très
fraternelles des affaires pour François
hand pour Nicolas malheureusement mais
évidemment évidemment il est bien mieux
placé que que que que François Holland
mais d'une certaine manière il est aussi
beaucoup alors pour disruptif moderne et
cetera je veux dire là je porte pas de
jugement mais simplement qui aurait
imaginé que qu'il serait accepté
unanimement il y a 20 ans 30 ans qu'un
ancien président fasse du business en
France ça aurait on aurait trouvé ça
hyper sale aujourd'hui ça pose plus de
problème et ben voilà l'époque a évolué
merci beaucoup merci à tous d' avoir
participé à ce débat je rappelle Étienne
Girard le livre le titre de votre livre
qu'écrit avec Laurent valdiguer donc le
parrain Sarco après Sarco l'enquête aux
édition du seuil merci à toutes et à
tous de votre fidélité vous êtes de plus
en plus nombreux à nous suivre à 18h et
22h sur public sénna ça fait plaisir on
va pas cacher notre notre bonheur on
vous dit à lundi et Notter que demain
dans la matinale Oriane Manini reçoit
Philippe rioot Le Maire de Grigny va
évidemment réagir aux mesures annoncées
par ellisabeth born 4 mois après les
émeutes belle soirée à toutes et à
[Musique]
tous